got a guy now who's 42 and tom brady who
you don't want to write him off i don't
want to overlook him i don't but you
know he he's getting upset right and we
saw last night he almost threw the
helmet we saw the lip reading and he was
he was trying to get his receivers to
get open and he doesn't have a guy who
commands double coverage and there were
reports he was salty about antonio brown
being cut and you know he didn't do much
to try to get gronk to come back he made
it clear he wasn't in the business of
trying to talk guys into into unretiring
but they just don't have the weapons
at what point though is it him
is it the what is how much
responsibility does he have for this
because the way he talks creates the
impression it's everyone's fault but his
yeah
so thank you because i do agree with
that yes it does seem like every you
know it's never tom's fault now tom's
still really good but like something
i've tried to argue with people in the
boston media over the last year and a
half two years he's not capable of
carrying the team anymore when
yes the right support system's not
around him you know and and like you
know to like what we're talking about
yeah he could never make plays like
desean watson where he'd scramble around
and make tack break tackles and do
things like that but what he could do
was
stand in the pocket fearlessly
move around the pocket make like
unbelievable throws because his arm is
special it's an all-time type of arm he
has and you know i think that where i
just see a little like you know cracks
in the armor is some flinchiness in the
pocket at times you know some
unwillingness to want to stand in there
and take the hit uh to make the throw he
wants um and that's where i see it see
it a little bit but like to your point
the support system's certainly not there
right now they don't have difference
makers they're not running the ball well
pass protection protection's an issue as
well um so it's not a great unit but
he's not at the point in his career
where he's going to be able to let make
them overcome it on a weekly basis
against certain teams i can't not wonder
what happens after this season his
contract expires he can go anywhere he
wants to go will he want to go try to
play somewhere else because there's
always this concern if i leave the
patriots yeah the patriots may thrive
without me you look at that roster that
roster ain't thriving without him right
who's going to play quarterback who's
going to play receiver how are they
going to retool in one off season that
side of the ball he may be better off
replacing drew brees in new orleans
replacing phillip rivers with the
chargers you know even even if
they're not dominant that's what he's
gonna have to ask himself
how do i feel about my chances to win
super bowl number seven next year if
they don't get to number seven this year
yes right do i feel strongly about it
new england or do i just keep playing
for someone else do i just you know they
went 10 years between winning super
bowls he had 10 fruitful and significant
seasons without a super bowl
championship you don't have to win it
every year right and at this age just to
keep playing to the extending wants to
boost the tb12 brand just keeping
playing is a big deal and if you're
playing for a high-profile team you know
if you end up with the saints replacing
drew brees if you end up with the
chargers replacing philip wherever you
go is going to become a high profile
team yeah and maybe he'd he'd like to to
free himself from just that that gloom
that always hovers over the patriots
because of bill belichick well yeah it's
it's a it's a grind it certainly is but
he's only you know he's synonymous with
the patriots i just can't imagine him
going
anywhere uh or playing football for any
other football team and also would
boston fans turn on him if he left i
don't think so i mean they might be mad
at him for a year or two but it's one of
those things where he he's already like
in the fabric and the dna of that city
forever and ever i mean he's got an
irish last name in boston and he wins
super bowls that's pretty unstoppable
there it would help to leave the
conference yeah i would definitely but i
look at it the other way too like you
know
mike i mean if they could this season
get
a receiver or two you know i think that
would make a big difference in the whole
outlook of the team in general you know
you know yeah it was antonio brown
whatever if they could get an aj green
or they you know end up making a move in
the draft to get a big time receiver
whatever it is it won't take a lot i
don't think i still think they're a team
that you know of course is ten and two
and one of the best in football but
offensively hey the offensive line it's
not great it's kind of having a down
year they've been banged up they've had
to deal with issues like that but i
don't think it's far off from being
really good and we saw it was really
good last year when they won the super
bowl you know the tight end position
that's hurt them so they've had to kind
of dance with a new formula as far as uh
that's concerned sony michelle hasn't
been as great you know and then they
just they need another receiver or
weapon to go along with julian edelman
and nikhil harry as he continues to
develop and muhammad's anu that's a
threat that can change coverages and
change how teams approach them right now
right now when you play the patriots
it's like something i've always said
with like aaron rodgers or some of those
guys it's like what are you worried
about when you play their offense who
scares you nobody really scares you if
you can take away julian edelman over
the middle of the field and all those
great plays they have designed for him
what else is going to beat you and i
think that's the big question uh that
they gotta kind of find the answer to
here down the stretch
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports